it's time to stop everybody sometimes in
life things just go too far and we have
reached that point everybody tech talk
videos that's right how many more videos
am I gonna milk from this slowest one
moderate Isis
I need that tick tock ad revenue it's
like they give it to you and take it
away anyway guys let's react to some
crunchy technique you see what I mean a
couple of weeks ago we saw this trend on
tick tock kids are starting to parody
these dumbass tick tock videos now it's
just gone full circle there's no actual
content left it's just kids trolling
each other 99% fortnight dances and I
don't even know what to describe some of
it I mean at this point no one is making
actual tick tock videos I can't find
actual tick tock
but let's go Melissa I'm clearly way too
old to look at this stuff that girl by
the way is the same girl that just a
stupid muffin song and I can't show them
I think song because the video will get
claimed but don't tell me I warned you
this it's about the ball and they say it
legends say if you watch this video too
long you will actually
you
contract
not living have you heard of lgbtq+ well
I am lippy as in Ben Shapiro destroying
live cards one at a time with pure facts
and knowledge that's great Ben Shapiro
has infiltrated tick-tock everybody
[Music]
hitting women is never okay
never hit a child what would you do if
there was a child right in front of you
it's so good she clearly is playing
along with it you can't go alright
I love the guy with the TV when earth is
gone wait been swallowed by a black hole
over the Sun itself
this video will still be going there
will still be kids making replies to
this one what if what if like I'm
getting some weird ideas kids keep using
tic toc it becomes this phenomena
phenomena you know what never mind
oh great it's this one matter miss I
guess they never amiss huh
you got a boyfriend I bet he doesn't
kiss here this is a dude what what this
is a perfect summary of tick tock
because first of all it's not a dude
second of all the fact that people think
it's a dude is the reason why this video
is popular give that give that some
thought for a minute okay the bully's
bonus app has gotten way out of hand
y'all need to grow up okay this is the
alternative version of me if I if I did
tik-tok videos instead of YouTube this
is how I would end up their bullying on
this app has to stop I never felt so all
this reviewing these video clips you
understand that right I don't take
pleasure in this it's like watching the
fall of society that's right sir society
it's society's fault you know I used to
think all these social justice thing was
bad look at the case look at what kids
are up to we're doomed it's over you got
to get this dog man to the frontlines
the furries they're coming I'll hold
them off though just keep passing it
what
all right now it matters - screams you
ruined it
good Wi-Fi in the kitchen
I mean yes finally kids are getting woke
they're taking the red pill finally are
there and they're asking the real
questions they wore we need to restore
and everyone oh my god this this will
win us the war and it's gone and it's
gone it's all gone what do you do we
stop get some help guys if a girl's ever
got you down just remember I want to be
chaser I'm already chaser so I can't
laugh at that I'm still extremely
disappointed I do not his life out of
spoon falling on a carpet I really hate
myself I really honestly I do if any of
you gamer boys are out here looking for
a gamer girl I'm here I've arrived and
this is your boyfriend application so to
apply all you have to do is do at this
tik tok showing me what you bring to the
table and then I'll pick my favorite
game room this is a trap
that's a trap okay sheis play Lee not
showed that she's a gamer how am I
supposed to know a girl is a gamer if
she doesn't show it how am I supposed to
understand if she's a gamer girl if she
at least you know if she's not choking
down on her video game controller huh if
a whamon isn't wearing epic video game
headphones and sucking on a controller
how am I supposed to believe you you're
not a game ago you're a faker girl learn
to spot one I may have just saved your
life you're welcome
[Music]
okay fine someone the more funny and
creative I will say that that doesn't
change the fact that I want to die okay
here miss I guess I never miss huh you
got a boyfriend I bet he doesn't kiss
yeah whoa spitting hit the dab look Wiz
Khalifa if any of you gamer boys out
there looking for a gamer girlfriend
well I'm here to tell you to focus we
have a warg into the furries to win and
we have no time for women
what has happened to team touch me
[Music]
why is she doing that though like is
there a reason she's doing that face or
is that her actual face hidden miss geez
I guess I'll be traced you got a
boyfriend but I want to be wind and you
should have finished reading the muffins
son cool so this is about the only
useful thing tick tock has done shown a
compilation of cats being petted
congratulations everyone congratulations
this is this is truly inspiring this is
it the internet working together to
actually make a difference well done
good job everyone
[Music]
why am i laughing at this this is so bad
which is what math is so great in our
mesh I bet you never miss huh
please
please please you see what I mean
these kids must be stopped we cannot let
them keep doing tick tock videos this is
just a beginning - what has it been like
two weeks this is too far really it's
officially gone too far I don't want to
see the end of it first I spill the milk
a few girls keep saying we're gonna port
me I'm gonna punch it on your face you
know what tick tock is back I love it
that's great
I have no idea what the context is I
don't even know if it's a joke but I
love it so I've been getting a lot of
salutes on my posts the past couple days
um can you guys stop please um women
don't deserve any respect what is
happened to it when they went from girls
just begging for attention with these
insane creams were they posed to girls
begging for attention with
self-deprecating ironic humor yeah I'm
okay with it
I'm okay with well dead so I was
thinking of making this hilarious video
where it's like so I'm doing a react and
the other videos like I don't know it's
something sad and then I responded by
doing a fortnight dance I think it's
done it before so I was thinking of
making this hilarious video where it's
like so I'm doing a react and the other
videos like I don't know it's something
sad and then I responded by doing a
fortnight dance I think it's gonna be
really funny because no one's ever done
it but it's so lame
it's so unoriginal it's so uninspired I
mean I have no one to talk really that
is a fake illness that's not even
realistic tonsillitis Cola fever
headaches or even a cough it's real and
diseases are real why would you make
that I'm so confused now I'm back at
being confused there's so many emotions
with tick tock it never ends
this
women bullying women it's awesome
finally okay that was it for this Tech
Talk video that's right everybody this
is the last one I promise guys don't
worry I will not upload I will not melt
this topic any further than it needs to
be just wanted to wrap it up with a
little little smile on your face so I
hope you enjoyed it's nice like if you
enjoyed
and I'll see you guys tomorrow Provost
[Music]